there's another site here I wanted to
talk about too is
um a man taking a woman's
virginity and somebody said you
shouldn't take her vCard and if you do
you should marry
her yeah I mean that that wasn't either
of us that made that statement are you
asking General thoughts on it yeah like
do you guys agree with that do you
disagree with that like what's your take
well I mean I personally think uh so one
of one of the things I noticed emerged
from the red pill sphere a few years ago
this might have been where it came up
was uh Tristan Tate the were clipse of
him floating around
talking yeah how to take a woman's
virginity and how to kind of butter her
up to give it up to you I think that's
insanely
degenerate um I think you know virginity
Christian man too though right now he is
he says he is I don't know to the fruits
of his lifestyle proveen no no so here's
an interesting concept so as as he's
done done in his past and he's openly
admitted to um offering advice on how to
take women's um you know virginity and
and I don't know if he was Christian at
this time or not if he repents does that
does that forgive him of those sins the
hard posture has to change anybody can
go to confession if you're a Catholic
anybody can say that they repent but God
knows the intentions of the heart
repentance is behavioral change it's not
just saying the words I Repent it's not
just saying our father or L Lord have
mercy upon me I'm a sinner it's more
than just words and Le that's why Jesus
cleansed the temple he went into the
temple flipping tables because they were
just all a bunch of you know they called
called them a brood of vipers and
whitewashed tombs and he was cleansing
the church because of their legalism and
that's the problem it's like any
Christian can profess that but are you
changing your behavior that's repentance
so so if a woman I don't know spends her
20s in her party years let's say she's
the average whatever girl pod podcast
with
the pink hair and all the other [__]
as an only fans uh you know goes through
about 50 guys can she repent from those
sins become Christian and expect to be
taken seriously from a guy would you
chase as a single man take a woman like
that
seriously it's a good question she's
she's a she's a woman of Christ she's
repented for her sins her heart's
changed but she still has 50 notches in
her I mean I think it's gross personally
I think any honest guy is going to say
that um would I take her seriously look
I'm not going to I don't I don't take a
woman seriously unless I see the fruits
of the spirit within her right so if I'm
talking to a girl and I don't get the
sense that she actually takes biblical
femininity seriously I'm not even going
to entertain it right if if if I'm not
getting the sense from her that she's
actually submitted to God I know not to
waste my time with her um a woman like
that that you're describing who has 50
bodies this is see this is the
interesting thing right proposing the
Christ pill
let's say tomorrow our society decided
to take the Christ pill and all of these
women out there with 50 to 100 bodies uh
became Christians
overnight they're going to have a hard
time finding quote unquote high value
men that are going to want to put up
with that and what I would propose to
those women if they you know take the
Christ pill they repent of their sins
they repent of their past so on and so
forth they ask Christ for forgiveness
what I would propose to all women in
that situation if you want guys to take
you seriously you better be the best
damn biblical wife candidate on the
planet that's the only way in my opinion
that you're going to make up for a 50 to
100 Notch count under your belt you have
to be the absolute perfect biblical wife
with zero question in a man's mind that
you know you your pair bonding abilities
have been compromised to the point where
you might want to divorce him and go you
know monkey Branch to another guy like
you and I both know all three of us know
Rich that
uh divorce rates obviously correlate
directly with the number of premarital
sexual partners that somebody's had so I
look at somebody with a 50 body count
and I'm like damn happiness as well
mental disorders lots of other things
correlate with body count body counts
traumatizing to women they don't
understand the significance of it yes
and you know I
think I think one of the one of the
beautiful things about Jesus Christ is
for somebody to get really deep into
their relationship with Christ it can
heal a lot of those traumas and and
mental and emotional disorders that can
come with a a damaged and troubled past
I've experienced that in my own life not
sexually but like you know with like
Trauma from stuff that happened in my
family the death of my mother so on and
so forth like God healed a lot of that
stuff for me and I believe that he can
absolutely do that for other people as
well but nonetheless I mean chick with a
50 body count it's it's a tough one to
swallow but if she's if she's the best
biblical wife
imaginable there's got out there that
would probably take her seriously if if
you had the choice between 50 body Camp
girl best biblical wife ever chased
she's virgin best you know best biblical
wife ever you're dating two girls who do
you
pick sorry both of them are Christians
you're saying yeah identical twins oh
both of them are Christians monical
twins they look exactly the same oh both
tens if both of them are Christians
obviously I'm going to pick the the
virgin no question yeah right yeah like
that's my point you know I I you know I
see all these um gals and Men send me
these screenshots all the time of um
dating profiles and you know these
conversations come up and it seems like
women want to be forgiven of their past
indiscretions and I don't I mean for me
personally obviously I'm I'm not a
religious person um I look at past
behaviors as a prediction of future
behavior and if you spent you know a
decade sharing your body with a whole
bunch of dudes and you want a man to
take you seriously and invite him into
your life and take care of you and take
on the risk of uh whether it's marriage
or living together whatever that happens
to be um you'd have to be an idiot to
take on a woman that's shared her body
with a bunch of men it's just not a good
proposition and I don't care who she's
uh asked for for forgiveness for from it
it it just doesn't make any logical
sense to me I think that's one of the
things that the swamp does get right um
or the red pill you know whatever you
want to call it and I don't think there
should be forgiveness for bad choices
like that because it's going to invite
bad problem like issues into your own
life like you're going to invite chaos
into your own life as a man so that's
just the idea of Perpetual condemnation
though right that's the idea that
Christianity is against the
misconception when I say Jesus can save
these hoes this is in response to myin
right is Hey listen I'm not saying that
men have to go out and marry them now it
doesn't mean that like hey okay just
because they're repentant their heart
posture truly is of is of repentance and
they want to live a virtuous life after
however many bodies that they've had
doesn't mean that they're going to get a
a good husband and I'll say this too
there are very real world consequences
to these actions much like a man who
slept with a bunch of women if there's
that you know virtuous virgin woman
who's disgusted by it well that's a
consequence he's got to live with as
well my whole response to this is what
is the alternative because you got these
men that are like I want to get married
but there's all these unmarriageable
women it's like listen and I know a lot
of people are going to disagree with me
on this and I've said this on the spaces
and and and Chase has heard me say this
before but a man does not sit in the the
shade of the tree that he's planted and
so for us to course correct that doesn't
mean hey man up and go marry these [__]
that nobody's saying that but a guy in
his own heart if he's repented he's been
forgiven especially as a Christian if
he's got a really good woman in front of
him that's been repentant of all these
things yes it's be it would be very wise
to weigh her the Pros against the cons I
can't tell a man what the body count
should be that he should just run away
you know we all have a sort of different
barometer obviously anything more than
zero obviously we're going to think hey
we shouldn't but I think we need to be
realistic and if we're going to fix the
problem instead of contributing to the
problem we have to sort of assess it
from that perspective versus there's no
there's no virgins anymore you know what
screw it I'm just going to go create
more hoes because it just perpetuates
the problem and it's a never ending
cycle well that's the other idea too
right it's just to indulge because
they're already promiscuous anyway so
what are you just going to witness the
decline it's just a Doomer mindset to me
and so there is a a well sorry um go
ahead Mike yeah no man I was just going
to say there was a secular liberal by
the name of JD Unwin I believe and he
did a study of civilizations right
before the the collapse of some major
civilizations and what he found and he
was he was trying to not find a
correlation between sexual Liberation
and the decline of society and he found
that there was a strong correlate
between those two things and so the
ultimate monogamy of previous
generations lasted multiple Generations
so we're going to talk about course
correcting I don't personally believe
it's a very masculine thing to do to say
you know what the ship's going down you
know what [__] it I'm going down with it
to me that's about as beta as you can be
because you've bent the knee to feminism
you're like you know what man I can't
influence it anyways I'm just going to
participate in this Indulgence and just
watch the decline that's not how I'm
going to participate in it I don't think
that's the way men should I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out